sprung out of this area Silicon Valley
area people started out doing most the
stuff in their garages and it really
does feel like the sky's the limit and
that's that's where the satisfaction
comes from is is anything can happen
you've probably heard of safety testing
for food products or agriculture
how about marijuana a new cottage
industry taking shape in California is
aiming to do just that
making weed safer for people with weak
immune systems through forensic testing
it's very important because every other
industry has some component of quality
control testing has regulations has
standards that's Josh were xored the lab
director at SC laboratories he's also
the creator of the company and gave us a
tour of his lab in Northern California
right now in California the medical
marijuana industry is basically kind of
a free-for-all I think a lot of people
are finally getting to the point where
they're like give us some sort of
guidance give us some sort of framework
to work within and then we at least know
where we stand if the words quality
control or regulations make you a bit
queasy you should know where's customers
which include dispensaries and growers
are stepping up to do this without any
sort of government agency forcing them
why promising safety to customers may
just be good business sense so I'm not
gonna just go take a bottle of aspirin
and you know I have nothing on the label
and have the doctor just be like well
take a few and see what happens same
thing with alcohol you're not gonna you
know any any bottle of alcohol you're
gonna buy is gonna give you information
on the amount of alcohol in that in the
beverage it's gonna give you a proof
there's a difference between a bottle of
wine and a bottle of whiskey exactly and
in this problem with a lot of the the
cannabis products are it's not it is
that it's not as easy to judge as it
might be with alcohol where you can you
can taste the extra extra alcohol in it
with cannabis especially with some of
these edible products it's a brownie and
who knows if they use an ounce of
cannabis to make that brownie if they
used a couple grams of cannabis Orser
showed us what he meant pointing out a
sample the lab was currently looking at
for a client over here this other major
peak we have is is THC Delta 9 THC
that's the the compound that actually
gives you the psychoactive response and
this right here is THC acid which is the
form of THC that the plant actually
produces according to where's our
dispensaries and growers are seeing a
lot of promise in the testing we have
several hundred clients across the state
and these are dispensary owners or
growers who do it voluntarily and it's
amazing to see the people who are
voluntarily coming to us paying a lot of
money to have us test their medicine
some of which doesn't pass and and just
to ensure that the patients that they
serve are as safe as possible now I know
what you're thinking how do you go about
this kind of testing without some sort
of standard words or says he works with
government and private organizations
that set standards for liquor and
they're always looking to other
organizations for guidance
our microbiological testing is pretty
universally used for foods and
nutriceuticals and other products like
that our pesticide tests come directly
from the epa and in our potency testing
we originally were using United Nations
Office on Drugs and Crime x' method that
they used to test seized cannabis we've
moved on and improved on their methods
but I mean so so all of our methods are
based in in in real world scenarios for
other products it's a lot of fun and
feels a lot to me like it probably felt
you know back 20 30 years ago when the
computer industry was taking off in this
area you know it's a lot of people are
in the kind of the sky's the limit you
feel like everyday you can kind of mold
the whole new industry and it have have
some sort of impact you know and when I
when I was working in lunch on of
materials industry I was just another
cog in in a giant machine here you know
it feels like like you can actually make
some change and have some influence and
you know the parallels are very similar
you know it's its sprung out of this
area Silicon Valley area people started
out doing most of the stuff in their
garages and it really does feel like the
sky's the limit and that's that's where
the satisfaction comes from is is
anything can happen
are you the Steve Jobs of cannabis
valley I wouldn't say that I would say
I'm having a lot of fun and I think I
get to meet the future Steve Jobs of
this industry on a daily basis so that
that's cool